Jonathan Turley you might agree with
that too but I won't ask you to comment
on that you're a Fox News contributor
you've been watching maybe you've been
watching us and I don't know what you
think about our legal analysis but let's
hear yours
well we're waiting to see what new
evidence they might have I mean one of
the more intriguing things is the
suggestion that they have a witness
tampering claim that may produce some
new evidence we haven't seen But You
Know Jack Smith has a reputation for
stretching criminal statutes beyond the
breaking point you know he he went after
the Virginia governor secured a uh
conviction there he was unanimously
overturned because he just stretched the
law too far Jonathan can I just
introduce you for one second and just
let you know that President Trump's
campaign has put out a statement saying
that he has been indicted and I know
that the grant as Davis bunches reporter
the grand jury apparently is sealed but
they're saying that shortly after 5 PM
the magistrate drudge in DC accepted
three new indictments then initials of
the first two were read aloud but not
the third that's the latest that we have
here so
I'll let me let you continue but I
wanted to just get that out there so
that we have the news on the record
right and as we expected uh this is the
other shoe dropping but you know the
there there's a a suggestion that Jack
Smith might be using the Civil Rights
Act and section 241 that would be a
stretch it has been used in some
election cases of interfering with the
right to vote but this goes to the
concern many of us have you know if
you're going to go after a prison or
former president you should do it on
well-established grounds you should do
it with overwhelming evidence you know
we can all debate the documents case but
that indictment is a fairly conventional
indictment it has it you know you
president Trump has denied the
allegations he'll have his day in court
this one it could be more problematic on
a legal basis I mean it you know this is
where Jack Smith may be yielding to his
weakness he may be stretching the law a
bit so that's why we're going to be
looking at things like witness tampering
to see how much new evidence he has you
you'll notice that not being discussed
in all of this is a conspiracy for
incitement not being discussed is a
seditious conspiracy those were the
claims that went into the second Trump
impeachment those were the claims the
Democrats said were lead pipe cinches
where the evidence was absolutely clear
they do not appear thus far to be in
this indictment but we'll have to see
the letter that was issued to Trump did
not include those specific allegations
right Jesse Waters Professor Tilley
what's the charge everybody keeps
talking about on the left that if Trump
is convicted of it disqualifies him from
ever
holding public office ever again is that
part of this
no I gotta tell you
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
we do have officials it's official now
the indictment has come down president
Trump has been indicted for you there
the indictment has happened and I I
think that you're in the middle of a
very good point answering the question
from Jesse Waters about does it the
Democrats think that there's something
in here that says president Trump can
actually serve as president again if he
were to win the election of 2024 back to
you Jonathan Turley
well you know the the Democrats have
been playing with this for years with
the 14th Amendment and the claims of
disqualification uh it's sort of a story
you tell your kids at night if you're a
democratic household so they sleep uh
restfully uh but I gotta tell you I'm I
highly skeptical I don't think that a
conviction would prevent Donald Trump
from running uh and by the way if he's
elected it wouldn't prevent him from
pardoning himself it wouldn't prevent
other Republicans uh elected from
pardoning him and if this doesn't go to
trial uh Jack Smith might never see a
jury because you can do a preemptive
pardon so there's a lot yeah I'm going
to interrupt you again which is very
rude and I'm going to owe you a drink we
want to get to David spun he actually
has the indictment
he can read it to us tell us what are
the charges or David's blunt there you
go over here we got the print we got the
printer going behind me 45 pages here it
is right here
um Donald Trump has been indicted there
are four different counts I want to read
them to you before I read through this
uh count one is conspiracy to defraud
the United States count two conspiracy
to obstruct an official proceeding count
three obstruction of an attempt to
obstruct an official proceeding and then
count four is called conspiracy again
against rights so I'm going to go
through this and look at it right now we
just sent it out so everybody should
have a copy in our email but right now
it appears four different counts uh this
was the indictment that was not read in
court now is unsealed uh and we're
waiting to see if we get any type of
reaction from special counsel Jack Smith
will be watching for do you know but
earlier earlier you said that there were
the indictments didn't have some
initials or some people were named what
happened to that is now everybody named
not everybody was named apparently we're
told from our producer in the courtroom
there were two cases where initials were
read were deciphering who those initials
may be we're waiting to see if we find
those but this specific case right here
uh there was no DT red or djt or Donald
Trump announced in the courtroom and
this just says United States of America
V Donald J Trump defendant so it does
not have other defendants listed in this
indictment we were wondering if perhaps
it might be Donald Trump and XYZ as we
saw uh with the retention of documents
case where his Aid in bodyman Walt NADA
was also indicted this right here is
just United States of America versus
Donald Trump it's four counts again
count one conspiracy to defraud the
United States count two conspiracy to
obstruct an official proceeding count
three is obstruction of an attempt to
four is conspiracy against rights it is
45 pages and on the back it has Jack
Smith's uh signature right here and it
just says right here here it says Donald
J Trump this is on the final page did
knowingly combine conspire con
confederate and agree with
co-conspirators known and unknown to the
grand jury to injure oppressed threaten
and intimidate one or more persons in
the free exercise and enjoyment of a
right and privilege secured to them by
the Constitution and laws of the United
States that is the right to vote and to
have one's vote counted in violation of
Title 18 United States code section 241.
thank you let's take it around the table
for some reaction to this now we have
the news Katie it is official your
thoughts uh David brought up the point
that it's only President Trump has been
indicted in this this round there could
be other people who end up getting
indictments just like we saw last week
with them bringing additional charges in
the classified documents case I wanted
to ask Jonathan Turley the question
about just the volume of legal work that
has to be done here there's the reports
that came out this week of President
Trump spending a lot of the campaign
money that's been given to him by donors
on his legal defense when you have 40
plus counts in the classified document
case four counts here the other
indictments that are coming right it
just I'm interested in just the sheer
volume of what that actually looks like
for attorneys getting ready for these
indictments into trials next year and
the amount of resources that's going to
take not just from them but from the
candidate himself when he's trying to be
on the the trail uh against again
President Joe Biden whose doj continues
to bring these charges Jesse your your
eyes are squinting there at a very very
tiny print so I think silly they lead
off with saying the president lied about
election fraud and knew there was no
fraud
how do they know that he knew that there
was no fraud and if this goes to trial
are we going to now have to go back and
find fraud in the 2020 election is this
now what we're going to go relitigate
does this open up the entire 2020
election
in a court setting to Donald Trump going
back and proving that there was indeed
fraud in presenting evidence of Fraud
and having that challenged in the court
is this really what we're going to do
and now they're saying that it was a
conspiracy
to fraudulently claim there was no fraud
that's what this is the first page I'll
let you know when I get to the second
part you keep if you would keep reading
there and there's another little bit of
news I can give to you so apparently
president Trump will appear in a federal
court on August 3rd I believe that's
Friday Friday August 3rd president Trump
to appear in federal court on this
latest indictment uh Greg Gutfeld do you
have any thoughts as we go around I
don't know what do you think what do you
think of my sketches uh when I'm usually
when I'm bored I will draw men in hats
I'm sure there's a psychiatrist out
there that can tell me what's wrong with
me I I kind of you know I look at this
stuff and I I honestly I just see again
it's worth it's just it's lawfare that's
all this we're not supposed to
understand this this is supposed to be
out of our hands out of our control
Donald Trump is probably one of the most
consequential leaders of our lifetime he
was outside the box he didn't play well
with others others being insiders this
is the payback he's not one of the kids
that he's not one of them he's the
outsider so this is just payback and
it's going to elevate him even more and
it's just not as fun as the other topics
we were going to do the other topics
were great there was a bear in China
Dana in a man's suit with a little butt
okay
um Jessica one thing that we had talked
about earlier and then we can Circle
back around now is that I whether these
are on the merits okay so let's see the
indictments come out the indictment's
just politically it's a fact that those
indictments so far have not hurt
president Trump politically in fact have
made him stronger you call them the
spinach yes
and I've said they're like the Pac-Man
ghosts every time you eat a ghost you
get a Little Bit Stronger that's more
updated than my stupid one everybody
knows Popeye in Spanish
um and so I wonder if the Democrats
think about what could happen if
reaction in the country is either to
shrug their shoulders or to think even
worse that maybe that there are these
two systems of justice and why isn't
this
um being applied to the vitamins I'm not
trying to equate January 6th then 100
Biden I'm just saying that it hasn't
helped Democrats politically so far do
you think that is going to change Or
democrats banking on that
no Democrats like they did in the 2022
midterms are running on issues they are
talking you can laugh all you want about
trying to convince people about Biden
economics or bionomics sorry I messed it
up
um but that doesn't mean that it isn't
what they're talking about I have not
seen one Democrat speech that's leading
with you know hey this guy you think
he's going to look good in an orange
jumpsuit they're talking about
whatever's going on in their District
they're talking about issues like the
Dobbs decision which was a complete
lightning rod in the midterms and will
continue to be so Democrats are doing
exactly what they should be doing which
is continuing to govern and continuing
to talk about the issues that matter to
Americans and
I think and this has been true almost
since you know Trump came down the
golden escalator the people's views are
very solidly baked in the people who
think that the Biden family is corrupt
and that they're the worst people on the
planet and really cared about you know
denying the seventh grandchild that was
one of our topics we were going to talk
about that
um that's done and dusted and the people
on the other side who said I can
absolutely never support Donald Trump
also done so it's just those few people
which is why the margins in these
elections are so slim are who the
persuadables are and what doesn't work
in the Republicans in favor with all of
this is that those people tend to think
that Donald Trump is guilty of these
things and they voted him out in the
last election in 2020 and we'll add he's
getting stronger as a candidate in the
polls but he is not financially Politico
has a big piece out today that as the
indictments continue to roll in he is
able to fundraise less and to Katie's
point he spent 40 million dollars on his
own defense which frankly sounds like a
better considered political Warfare
right yeah
but they're real charges
I was also just thinking Katie that
with these indictments if if you're the
Trump team or president Trump himself
given that these indictments are coming
out and he'll be in court on Thursday
August 3rd I had the date right but the
day wrong so Thursday August 3rd
to me if I were him I would definitely
want to be on the debate stage on August
23rd because then he could be in a
position to look at all of the people
around him including Chris Christie a
big critic of his and say who here
thinks that this indictment of me was
fair right and see what happens and be
able to put them all on record and try
to seal up the commanding lead that he
already has that's just something that
came to me yeah and I mean certain
candidates like Nikki Haley have have
come out and said this is a distraction
we don't want to be talking about this
with the nominee uh next year but the
truth is Republicans are in the place
they're trying to defeat Trump but they
they really can't go after him on this
issue because doj has been so corrupt
and there's so much information about
how the FBI was behaving during the 2016
election and during President Trump's
first term that you end up defending the
institutions that quite you know all a
lot of the time are going after
Republican political candidates when
your question question about your
statement about the um the money being
you know going away and not being
political Warfare as well it is I mean
this is a way for them to bleed Donald
Trump dry when it comes to campaign
fundraising and that's exactly what
they're doing with all of these
indictments and so it would be great for
him to show up and ask it's also hurting
State Republican parties the the swing
state Republican parties have the worst
Financial records and they're the ones
that are supposed to pay for get out the
vote ballot
um I'm gonna say harvesting but figuring
out a way to get those ballots mailed in
and everything okay Jonathan Turley you
uh stuck around and Katie had a question
that she put wanted to pose to you
earlier and it had to do with just the
amount of legal work that is going to be
required here
well for these lawyers it probably feels
like death by a thousand paper cuts uh
he's looking at now his third indictment
he's expecting a fourth indictment uh
you know this is not like frequent flyer
miles where the fourth one's free uh you
know these lawyers have to work on each
of these cases they've got to line up uh
Witnesses they have to have access to
their clients to deal with specific
representations to be made I at some
point the judges are going to have to
acknowledge uh that you can't just you
know destroy uh defended by exposure you
know you have to give the defendant a
chance to focus at least on one case
someone's got to go first on top of that
they gave them a May date for the First
Federal indictment but then they hit him
with a superseding indictment with new
counts and a new defendant that's going
to have to weigh on the court as to
whether it's fair now to stick with the
original date given that change and this
additional indictment and one coming
wait so we're just in my ear they just
told me that there are six unnamed
co-conspirators so we don't know who
those people are yet but will we and
what are are they going does this mean
they're indicted as well
yeah I've been reading uh through this
indictment uh they don't name some of
these individuals but we can guess who
they are I have to tell you I am I
really quite astonished by much of this
indictment so far it regurgitates a lot
of the allegations against Trump and
there is room for criticism uh in terms
of the claims being made about stolen
elections uh but it's criminalizing all
of that you know it states in the
indictment the president spent months
spreading false rumors and allegations
of election
irregularities really is that a criminal
issue I mean is that is that the basis
of this conspiracy uh it seems to me
rather loose at the joints and you know
I'm I'm a bit surprised I haven't seen
anything in the indictment so far which
is new you know we heard about witness
tampering and things of that kind this
is largely going through the states
Arizona Georgia restating what has been
in the press it even includes reference
to that phone call where the President
says all you have to do is find eleven
thousand votes you know for those of us
have looked at that phone call that
doesn't seem to be a criminal matter if
you look at it fairly uh the president
seems to be saying all I need is 11 000
votes so when we're looking at a recount
uh we're not talking about a huge
threshold for us to show that the
election should have come out
differently yet Smith throws that in and
so I think that as I said before the
indictment came down the concern was
this would play to Smith's weakness that
he tends to stretch evidence stretch the
law when he wants to go after someone
I'm still looking in this indictment for
something that is really a sort of aha
moment I'm going to get to Jesse in just
one second but let me just press you a
little bit so on the you said that we
could guess who the co-conspirators are
do you want I I'm actually not sure do
you do you want to speculate or do you
want to just well you know he
so while he refers to attorneys that he
enlisted that would probably be John
Eastman okay uh Giuliani those types of
people are likely to be the reference
points here got it Jesse well the
indictment reads like a transcript of an
MSNBC show first point they said the
defendant impaired the federal
government from functioning isn't that
literally the Republican Party platform
to reduce the ability of the federal
government for functioning and then they
said it's a crime to ask Pence not to
certify
I wonder if Pence would agree that that
was a crime apparently the campaign
managers told the defendant Donald Trump
he had a five to ten percent chance of
of winning these challenges but he still
fought on the indictment said how dare
he with five to ten percent chance I
wonder what the guys in Vegas would say
you now have suspicious activity in
Philadelphia Detroit
and Arizona and Nevada
they're going to have to litigate
suspicious election activity in all of
those States
they're going to be presenting evidence
the defense is going to be presenting
evidence and then the prosecution is
going to have to knock that down we're
going to relitigate all of these deep
blue Democrat districts over the entire
country in court in 2024 in election
year that's really do you think that's
healthy for the country Jonathan Turley
and do you think that's a road that
Democrats want to go down to defend the
Integrity of Philadelphia's election
security and then they're saying the
Trump said the voting machines weren't
secure again we're going back to voting
machines at trial
in court in an election year we're going
to bring in voting machine Executives
who explain everything's fine and then
they're up on cross-examination we're
going to go through that again Jonathan
Turley and then lastly they're saying
lying about an election is illegal
well then Hillary
lock her up John Kerry too
all right uh good point but Jonathan
Turley you should respond not me
haha well I you know this is what I was
addressing before the indictment came
down I was hoping that if there were an
indictment then you would have this
moment where you say okay I get it I you
this could be debated uh but you've got
something new here I haven't seen
anything particularly new and you know
the the indictment goes through and says
look all these people told him that he
lost the election all these people said
that that Pence couldn't do that I was
one of the people writing at that time
saying I thought that the president was
wrong about a vice president Pence but
he was also hearing from attorneys that
said that we can win that Pence can do
this and so you're going to be
criminalizing a difference of opinion
now it's true that most attorneys did
not support that view but once again it
goes to what do you need to bring an
indictment against President former
president what does the public expect
for a lot of people in the public this
is going to look like you know the
indictments will continue till the polls
change and that's not what you want
right I want to Brian Kilmeade I want
you do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now